this video is sponsored by the self-care
app fabulous the first 100 people to
click the link in the description will
receive 25 off their subscription
we want to experience so much in life we
can often ignore and neglect the quality
of what we actually experience
we are so often drawn to lifestyles full
of busy schedules active social lives
frequent travels and elaborate goals and
achievements we end up in lives focused
on all of these things but very little
on ourselves
the busy life is promoted to us by
culture in movies in shows the news
best-selling books on social media and
so on for much of the modern world the
ideal of this life is transfused into
the blood but is this way of life even
good for you
since oftentimes people who live very
simple modest quiet lives are viewed as
unexceptional unsuccessful losers and so
on it can perhaps be hard to see a quiet
simple life of relative obscurity as
something appealing noteworthy
intentional and difficult
but in truth for at least some portion
of us this sort of life is in fact a
redeeming endeavor indicative of immense
discipline and wisdom
if a man does not keep pace with his
companions perhaps it is because he
hears a different drummer
let him step to the music he hears
however measured or far away
wrote 19th century american
transcendentalist writer and philosopher
henry david thoreau
thoreau was a figure who focused much of
his life and philosophy on the value of
simplicity self-reliance authenticity
and separating from the influences and
conventions of modern life
he not only wrote about these concepts
but he lived them
after avoiding the expected standard
career paths and befriending the
founding father of the transcendentalist
philosophy movement ralph waldo emerson
for years thoreau lived by himself in a
cabin in the woods on a plot of
emerson's land
here he led a simple quiet secluded life
focusing only on what he believed he
truly needed and valued he worked only
one day a week reduced his material
possessions to a minimum separated from
the social and cultural world immersed
into nature and focused on his passion
of writing
during this time he wrote his master
work walden in one passage of this book
he reflects on his time and reasons for
living alone in the woods writing i went
to the woods because i wish to live
deliberately to front only the essential
facts of life and see if i could not
learn what it had to teach and not when
i came to die discovered that i had not
lived i wanted to live deep and suck out
all the marrow of life
we all want to live a good life and be
successful but how often do we stop and
evaluate what a good successful life
might be for us how often do we consider
not how it would look from the outside
but how it would feel from the inside
the only place it is actually
experienced
plainly being successful merely means
having adequately accomplished a
predetermined goal or task and so
arguably being successful in life
depends solely on having mindfully
determined an overarching goal for how
you want to live and then living
adequately that way
thus those who live a quiet modest
simple life are just as successful as
someone who lives a busy and culturally
significant one so long as in both cases
both ways of life are intentionally
pursued both are equally successful when
obtained
only in the case in which someone is
living unintentionally and without
deliberation is one unsuccessful
thus even on the highest of thrones the
remotest of destinations and the most
private of rooms we might just as likely
find examples of failure as we might in
a small cabin in the woods
of course some of us might find
ourselves in conditions and
circumstances we did not choose that
cannot easily be broken free from
conditions that come with financial
mental or health constraints and
responsibilities that require ways of
life that we may not prefer
and of course many of us do prefer busy
frantic material lives
but for the number of us for whom this
is not the case if we choose to give up
our time to people and things we don't
value that take us from people and
things we do where a different
accessible orientation of our life would
not require this then perhaps we have
ventured the wrong direction and would
benefit from some amount of
simplification or at the very least a
reasonable renovation of our lives
inevitably we almost give up some
portion of our time to people things and
tasks that we do not want to but the
essential question we must ask ourselves
when we can is how much why and for what
we all know that time is the only
commodity that cannot be earned or
bought back when it is gone and in a
fundamental sense it is the only thing
we truly have and yet we often exchange
it haphazardly for reasons we don't
think much about we would never let
anyone take our money or our car or any
of our stuff but yet we often freely let
people and things and experiences take
our time every day month year and decade
and here is where we might call upon
thoreau emerson and other great thinkers
alike to realize the value of our
deliberateness and focus on our time our
perception and the internal experience
of our lives and not on things other
people's opinions and that which we
cannot control outside of ourselves
in short thoreau wrote i am convinced
both by faith and experience that to
maintain oneself on this earth is not a
hardship but a pastime if we will live
simply and wisely
perhaps we don't always need to take
that new job with those greater
responsibilities accept that invitation
to that concert or that party go to that
place we've seen everyone go keep as
many relationships with as many people
as we can try to keep up with everyone
we know and see online or buy that new
version of that new thing
perhaps rather for some of us we would
be better served by focusing on how to
draw down the items on the to-do list
the events on the calendar the people we
engage with and instead keep a
relatively concise schedule with just a
few important things and a few important
people
in truth an exciting life is a life in
which we are excited to be alive not
necessarily one in which we are always
frantically doing things
there is nothing impressive about living
a life you do not like if you do not
have to and there is great virtue and
heroism and simply staying sane kind
spending meaningful time with a few
close loved ones and maintaining
authenticity in one's work and life
of course none of this is to make light
of the difficulty of doing such a thing
and living such a way
swimming against the current of social
conventions of personal and cultural
expectations of what you're currently
doing is like trying to get back to the
shoreline while the force of the ocean's
current pulls you further and further
out to sea and moreover the ambiguity of
what we actually want and what is
actually good for us is always present
the temptation of the alleviation of
responsibility by just letting the
current take us and living how others
live defining success and excitement how
others define it spurs in every post on
social media and intimates in every
encounter in which we are asked what do
you do
but in the words of thoreau
rather than love then money then fame
give me truth
to find truths and values the row look
to nature independence and a life of
simplicity but arguably where we look is
perhaps far less important than why we
look where we do
it is in thoreau's deliberateness that
we should draw inspiration from not
necessarily his lifestyle a successful
life is not one filled with important
meetings active social lives high wealth
or fame but nor is it one reduced to its
most basic form filled primarily with
free time and leisure
a successful life is simply a conscious
one one made of authenticity
self-reliance and continual adaptation
toward who we are and how we want to
live
in the end the only shame of being
unsuccessful in life is being
unsuccessful in living how you want to
the best you can
this video was sponsored by
fabulous
an essential part of simplifying and
leading an intentional life is defining
the basic things that we find important
and then constructing habits and
routines around those things so they
stick somewhat ironically though
sometimes it's the simple most important
things that can be the hardest to do
this for eating and sleeping well
exercising or meditating staying
hydrated focused and calm all are about
as basic and important as you can get
but yet a great many of us struggle
doing these things and understandably so
the modern world often demands more of
us than there is to give the self-care
app fabulous is like a digital coach
that helps make the process of
developing and sticking to an
intentional life easier and more
rewarding by using science-backed
principles and a range of functions and
features fabulous helps you break down
long-term goals into small tasks that
build into consistent daily routines
you can pick from more than a hundred
habits or create your own and then use
fabulous's notifications tracking
function and other features to take a
more self-guided approach or immerse in
the fabulous dedicated programs
behavioral change programs and journeys
for additional help in discovering and
forming the best habits and methods
suited to your long-term goals whether
you're struggling with stress and would
benefit from a habit of meditation or
daily walks want to sleep or eat better
or simply want to be more focused and
consistent on your work fabulous
provides a personalized and rewarding
experience that can help turn just about
any goal into a part of your regular
daily routine
start building your ideal daily routine
today by clicking the link in the
description below the first 100 people
to use the link will get 25 percent off
their subscription
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you